[Musique]
quel est le principal préjugé dont
souffre l'Afrique
cela dépend de qui porte ce préjugé si
on considère que c'est un préjugé qui
est forgé en Occident on va dire que
sans doute c'est considéré que
l'Africain en train de retard qu'elle
n'a pas pris la marche du monde il y a
un procès en arriération qui lui est
fait c'est vrai oui bien sûr parce qu'on
entend souvent dire beaucoup de choses
en général très négatif
c'est un pays c'est un continent qui est
lapsus c'est un continent qui est
sous-développé
les populations sont portées dans
l'histoire mais ce qui m'interpelle moi
aujourd'hui c'est lorsqu'on voit les
sociétés qui sont développées ces
sociétés capitalistes qui ont
épuisé la planète dans une économie
extractiviste on s'interroge enfin moi
je m'interroge savoir au fond qui est
moins développé que qui l'Afrique
aujourd'hui et en train de repenser un
modèle le développement propre qui soit
endogène qui soit moins dépendants
je dirais de l'accident ou c'est ça
c'est
moi dépendant de l'Occident aussi bien
sûr mais surtout qui ne soit plus
arrimer à un cahier des charges qui lui
avait été dictée indiqué depuis toujours
le l'Afrique c'est quand même construit
dans le regard des autres
avec des injonctions qui l'ont été
imposées pendant plusieurs décennies
voire depuis la colonisation et
aujourd'hui elle est en train d'essayer
de de se réinventer en adaptant ses
besoins en réalité des populations et
non pas en se soumettant à desiderata
étrangers occidentaux vous dites il y a
une espèce de critique récurrente assez
négatives sur l'Afrique or on entend
aussi un peu le contraire en disant mais
l'Afrique c'est le continent de demain
c'est le continent où il y a toutes les
richesses et c'est accident de l'avenir
on l'entend ça aussi quand même oui bien
sûr on entend ça mais en même temps ça
veut dire que en ce moment si on dit que
c'est content de l'avenir cela indique
en creux que pour le moment l'Afrique
n'est pas aujourd'hui on y son existence
telle qu'elle est telle sa manière
d'être présente d'être présente au monde
et en réalité on se projette sans cesse
et on se projette aussi comme un
continent qui serait où il n'y aurait
pas de population un continent qui
serait simplement un vivier de
ressources qu'on pourrait extraire n'est
pas une elle est multiple il y a
plusieurs Afrique si on est au cap on
n'est pas à Alger si on est à Abidjan on
n'est pas à Djibouti elle est très
différente cette Afrique non oui bien
sûr c'est une Afrique et diversifiée il
y a des cultures qui sont différentes
des populations
un rapport au monde qui même si on peut
considérer de façon globale et un peu
rapide elle-même il y a quand même
beaucoup de singularité moi je viens du
Cameroun
et parfois j'ai
l'altérité pour moi à certains moments
c'est le le Sénégalais plutôt que
quelqu'un qui m'aime peut-être peut-être
que la mer indien par exemple donc oui
je crois aujourd'hui que on le dit de
plus en plus dans le dit pas assez que
l'Afrique ce n'est pas un tout uniforme
compact où chacun peut déverser ses
propres projections et ses fantasmes
alors troisième chose
vous dites elle veut exister par
elle-même cet Afrique ou ses Afrique
qu'elle a une singularité qu'elle a de
richesse qui n'est pas uniquement une
richesse du sous-sol c'est qu'elle a une
richesse artistique incroyable
aujourd'hui quand vous regardez un petit
peu toutes les influences
portées par l'Afrique dans toutes les
musiques du monde
dans l'art culinaire
en littérature vous qui est écrivain qui
est romancière un livre qui a fait
beaucoup parler de lui pas très il y a
pas très longtemps qui s'appelle les
aquatiques il y a une profusion
d'écrivains sur le continent africain
dont on disait que c'était le continent
de leur réalité oui je pense simplement
que
ces écrivains là ces talents ont
toujours existé peut-être que simplement
c'est une aire qui a changé et les gens
s'intéressent de plus en plus à ce qui
se produit sur le continent le premier
livre a été créé en Afrique par Thomas
morphologie africain en 1907
et depuis la production africaine a
cessé d'être
profuse à abondante simplement il y
avait ce préjugé dont vous parliez dès
le départ qui était c'est le continent
de leur réalité c'est le continent des
ténèbres et puis surtout ce rapport de
subalterne qui a été institué avec la
colonisation faisait que de l'Afrique on
attendait pas grand-chose et aujourd'hui
je crois que les gens ont commencé à le
monde l'Occident a commencé à réviser ce
regard là mais aussi parce que il y a
des Africains qui s'élèvent aujourd'hui
qui a moi qui se font entendre et puis
des discours qui sont prononcés par les
Africains eux-mêmes et non pas seulement
au nom des Africains l'émergence d'une
casse ce qu'on appelle une classe
moyenne oui tout à fait oui une réalité
oui elle est de plus en plus
prépondérante alors il y a un discours
qui a fait beaucoup de bruit en France
et en Afrique en Afrique beaucoup
beaucoup ces discours de Nicolas Sarkozy
en
2007 à peine élu d'ailleurs il va à
Dakar et il dit que le problème de
l'Afrique c'est que l'homme africain
n'est pas rentré dans l'histoire c'était
le 26 juillet 2007 et ce jour-là Nicolas
Sarkozy déclenchait la polémique avec
cette phrase
le drame de l'Afrique c'est que l'homme
africain
n'est pas assez entré dans l'histoire
alors c'est un discours qui a été écrit
par Henri Guaino qui est un gaulliste de
la première heure et c'est un discours
qui a des accents parfois effectivement
un peu infantile pour pour la fréquence
vous l'avez reçu vous
j'ai été heurté comme beaucoup
d'Africains sur le continent d'africain
de la diaspora à travers le monde on a
été heurté et puis en même temps j'en ai
ri j'en ai ri parce que ça traduisait
quand même l'ignorance d'un président de
la République en période publique
française
tenir de tels propos lorsqu'on sait que
par exemple la charte de du monde de
kurokan Fouga date du 13ème siècle alors
que la Déclaration des droits de l'homme
et du citoyen en France date du 18e
siècle cette charte elle
[Musique]
elle souligne la primauté de la vie sur
le reste elle indique qu'il n'y a pas de
discrimination possible entre les vies
qu'il n'y a pas une vie plus ancienne
une vie plus jeune et que tous les
hommes sont égaux et ça c'est au 13e
siècle il y a eu de grands empires en
Afrique des royaumes je peux revenir sur
tout cela et d'entendre la président
français s'exprimer ainsi c'était une
très grande légèreté et puis et puis une
faute
ça considérablement attaquer son sa
réputation en Afrique ou parce qu'il y
avait quand même les présidents français
ont toujours été plutôt bien accueillis
en Afrique en général à la télé oui
alors oui les présidents français
bénéficiaient d'un crédit plutôt positif
pendant plusieurs années notamment parce
que c'était aussi dans des pays qui
étaient
gérés de manière assez ferme par des
pouvoirs autocratiques donc dans la
société civile chez intellectuels
c'était souvent un accueil plutôt
contrasté et puis un regard qui était
assez critique c'est pas pour ça que la
population
[Musique]
sur eux la manière dont ils ont été
objectivés par les anthropologues les
ethnologues et finalement une parole qui
leur a été confisquée pendant très
longtemps c'est pour ça que moi par
exemple dans dans ma démarche artistique
il est important que je raconte les
histoires de l'Afrique et que moi comme
d'autres qu'on raconte notre propre
histoire avec c'est à vous de raconter
votre histoire oui je ne dis pas que
c'est seulement à moi mais c'est à moi
aussi cela a été empêché pendant très
longtemps les Africains écouter des
discours qui étaient tenus sur eux et
quelque part ils ont construit leur
subjectivité à travers ces discours là
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est de moins
en moins possible puisque on s'est rendu
compte que les ces voies minorée là se
fait de plus en plus entendre quand elle
se faisait entendre ce n'était pas tout
à fait la même la même manière que
lorsqu'on parlait d'elle et je crois
qu'on ne peut reconstruire son
identité la confiance en soi que
lorsqu'on a
des repères des repères qui vous sont
transmis par vos par le passé par les
aînés par une société je en Afrique au
Cameroun notamment il y a cette phrase
là qu'on entend souvent elle avait
laquelle j'ai grandi qui est lorsque
quelqu'un est raffiné éduqué ou à une
belle réussite on dit de lui c'est un
vrai blanc je ne sais pas si vous vous
rendez compte en creux de ce que ça dit
ça veut dire que l'horizon a atteindre
c'est être blanc ça veut dire que les
talons le maître étalon du succès de la
beauté de la de la réussite
c'est l'occidental et en creux comment
ça ça déni
cette disqualifie les Noirs les
Africains
encore aujourd'hui combien de fois je me
suis fait traiter de de vraies blanches
comme un compliment ce qui pour moi est
une insulte extrême pas parce que je
j'ai un problème à traiter de blanche
mais parce que c'est encore une
survivance de l'héritage colonial ou ce
qui était blanc était forcément bon et
parait de toutes les vertus et qualités
alors c'est peut-être en train quand
même de changer même dans l'approche que
les Occidentaux en tous les cas en
France ont de l'Afrique et on l'a vu
récemment avec le président de la
République qui a accueilli un sommet il
y avait une tradition en France les
sommets France Afrique je crois que le
premier à l'avoir organisé d'ailleurs
c'est le président Giscard d'Estaing et
sommets où il y avait que les chefs
d'État et là en 2021 le président de la
République a décidé que ce sommet aurait
lieu à Montpellier et que ce sommet ça
serait lui et
son cabinet mais avec la société civile
africaine et donc il y a des
intellectuels des des acteurs de la
société civile africaine de qui venait
de partout en Afrique qui sont venus
dialoguer avec lui et là ils lui ont
fait ils ont pas ménagé leur critiques
vous avez suivi un peu ce sommet là non
oui bien sûr c'était nouveau et c'était
une initiative qui sur le principe était
intéressante ça faisait suite au
discours de Ouagadougou de novembre 2017
le président Macron avait décidé de
réinventer la relation non pas France
Afrique mais Afrique France
je l'ai quand même précisé même quand on
dit France Afrique c'est France et le
prêt carré français en Afrique parce que
ça aussi c'est pas toute l'Afrique c'est
important de le préciser donc maintenant
qu'un président français décide de ne
plus faire de sommet avec des chefs mais
plutôt avec une société civile et une
jeunesse africaine pourquoi pas mais ça
interroge pourquoi cette société civil
là ça représentant ont été choisis par
les ambassades de France dans les pays
où ils ont été invités alors sur quels
critères comment c'est opérer le choix
je ne sais pas et je crois aussi que
pour l'iconographie de voir
même dans une démarche de révolution et
de changement ou de rééquilibrage de ces
relations là de voir un président tout
seul face à une jeunesse d'un continent
pour moi je trouve que ça pose problème
ça pose problème parce que ce n'est pas
réversible comme situation j'imagine
très mal un président africain
française même pas française européenne
dans une ville dans une ville africaine
voilà donc ça c'est encore un signe
c'était une image de verticalité
d'asymétrie de la relation même si je
peux comprendre l'INT le départ qui
était ok on va écouter cette jeunesse là
on va écouter ses aspirations et
d'ailleurs les débats ont été
effectivement très intéressants en même
temps pour reprendre une expression qui
lui est familière au président Macron
quelques mois après c'est retour à
l'arrière politique parce que finalement
ces détails à état qu'on discute et et
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé qu'est-ce qui
se passe depuis quelques mois c'est le
retour
dans les capitales africaines à la
rencontre des présidents ces présidents
même qu'on ne jugeait plus comme
interlocuteur valable pendant le Sommet
de Montpellier tout ça ça m'interroge la
volonté d'émanciper d'émancipation n'est
pas complètement
je dirais sincère et elle n'empêche pas
les relations d'état à état ça ne peut
pas d'ailleurs être effacé ça les
relations d'État est un oui bien sûr
mais je pense juste qu'entre le discours
et les actes qu'on pose il y a une
dissonance et cette dissonance là elle
elle se situe dans l'interstice de la
réalité une réalité où il faut bien
défendre les intérêts des entreprises
françaises où il y a des intérêts qui
sont en jeu et ça devient très très
compliqué de simplement dire ok on a
entendu la jeunesse africaine on a
entendu les critiques on va désormais ne
plus traiter avec certains pouvoirs
peut-être non démocratique on va
vraiment être dans une relation
d'égalité avec l'altérité africaine
il y a un drame que vit l'Afrique quand
même il y en a plusieurs évidemment avec
le réchauffement climatique avec
des gouvernements qui sont pas vraiment
des gouvernements très démocratiques
c'est moins qu'on puisse dire il y a des
fléaux comme le paludisme on en parle
jamais d'ailleurs pas assez mais qui
sont réels et il y a l'immigration aussi
comment on à cette immigration de masse
de beaucoup d'Africains qui cherchent à
d'Eldorado en Europe notamment aux
États-Unis alors avant d'arriver à
l'immigration je voudrais quand même
souligner que l'Afrique n'est pas le
seul continent qui vit de multiples
drames et c'est vrai que lorsqu'on les
additionne comme ça on a l'impression
que c'est cette plage d'Égypte mais
c'est en Afrique au-delà de tout ce
qu'on peut voir dans les médias à la
télévision il y a aussi une qualité de
vie il y a une sociabilité il y a il y a
plein de
il y a aussi une vie que beaucoup
notamment la diaspora recherche à
nouveau quand il rentre vivre en Afrique
quand ils sont plus en Afrique oui tout
à fait alors comment est-ce qu'on au
drame de l'immigration
il y a plusieurs pistes qui se qui ont
été explorées je vais pas enfoncer les
portes ouvertes mais ce qui est sûr à
mon sens c'est que tant que les
gouvernements en Afrique n'offriront pas
des conditions viables à leur jeunesse
ne seront pas plus démocratiques
[Musique]
Voilà
la démocratie nous ne combattrons pas
plus efficacement la corruption ce sera
très difficile pour cette jeunesse là
qui aspire qui a fait des études souvent
c'est pas comme vous le savez ce ne sont
pas les plus pauvres qui immigrent c'est
souvent ceux qui ont les moyens de payer
un passeur de pouvoir payer en voyage de
corrompre des agents qui leur facilitent
des visas dans certaines ambassades donc
c'est le signe que aujourd'hui en
Afrique l'aspiration
ultime c'est l'Europe en fait et donc il
faut à la fois que les gouvernements
peut-être soit plus démocratique et
permettent des conditions de vie
meilleure à leur population mais aussi
que chacun enfin nous notamment dans la
société civile qu'on puisse refait
gronder les imaginaires c'est quoi
refait gronder les imaginaires c'est
très joli
c'est travailler chaque jour à ce que
jeunesse là se rendent compte qu'autour
d'elle elle vit dans des pays
exceptionnels où il y a de la ressource
des pays qui sont enviés et que chacun a
son échelle peut apporter quelque chose
donc il y a aussi un attentisme qu'il
faut combattre cette attentisme étant
puisque l'État ne fait rien on va aller
en Europe voir ailleurs voir si la bête
plus verte je crois qu'il faut regarder
aussi attentivement ce qu'on a nos
potentialités et voir comment est-ce
qu'on peut les développer c'est une
dynamique globale moi je suis bien sûr
qu'on attend beaucoup de l'État mais je
suis de celle qui pense que chacun a son
échelle quand on a une voix qu'on peut
faire entendre il est important que
cette voie là puisse avoir une résonance
auprès de ceux qui
n'en n'ont pas et auprès de ceux qui
s'imaginent que l'Europe c'est la
panacée vous êtes Franco camerounaise
c'est dur de d'être d'une double culture
en ce qui me concerne vraiment je parle
à moi l'échelle pas individuelle mais
identités sont vraiment miscibles et et
je gère très bien à la fois
je n'ai pas un pied en Afrique et un
pied en France j'ai à la fois des pieds
en France et depuis en Afrique donc à
chaque fois que je me retrouve sur l'un
des continents dans l'un des univers les
deux se retrouvent fécondés en réalité
et donc c'est vraiment un réel
enrichissement je crois que le problème
peut se poser peut-être pour ceux qui
viennent de zones du Monde minorée et
qui par ailleurs porte une identité au
moins visible
occidentale et qui se retrouvent comme
ça à la confluence de différentes
identités qui sont difficiles à assumer
ou alors pour dire les choses simplement
ceux qui sont d'ici de France qu'on
renvoie sans cesse à un ailleurs dans
lequel ne se reconnaissent pas ça
devient beaucoup plus compliqué mais
c'est Césaire qui disait que l'universel
et riche de tous les particuliers je
trouve ça formidable donc moi
j'additionne mes identités et et ça crée
en moi peut-être ça qui me donne la
force de créer
je suis disait je suis un additionné ah
ça c'est ça je pense que je suis et je
suis une additionnée et je le revendique
oui alors il y a une singularité au
Cameroun
par rapport à d'autres pays
qui ont été colonisés c'est les
Allemands qui avaient mis la main sur ce
pays 18 et après il y a eu le Congrès de
Berlin donc les Allemands et puis les
Allemands ont perdu la guerre de 14-18
et le le pays est revenu à la Société
des Nations à l'époque il a donné à
gérer à la fois aux Anglais et on voit
le Cameroun et
aux Français alors il faut le savoir
quand on regarde la carte du Cameroun
c'est que les Français c'était plutôt la
partie orientale les Anglais plutôt la
partie
occidentale c'est-à-dire vers le Golf de
Guinée et au nord c'était plutôt il y
avait encore quand même une résurgence
allemande donc c'était un pays qui a été
sous triple influence on va dire c'est
pas simple quand même
après aujourd'hui de trouver une unité à
ce pays je pense que le Cameroun
aujourd'hui l'influence allemande a
vraiment disparu je crois que les
derniers populaires personne qui
parlaient allemand ou qui avec la
colonisation allemande ne sont plus ne
sont plus de ce monde c'est beaucoup
plus on va dire les blocs francophones
et anglophones une unité qui n'est pas
simple à trouver mais quand on essaye
quand même d'articuler
certes dans le nord-ouest sud-ouest il y
a des tensions extrêmement fortes pour
pour dire le moins et depuis 2016 c'est
une zone qui est entrée en rébellion
mais ça c'est
héritage effectivement que la
colonisation puisque ces populations là
étaient étaient au fond les mêmes et
elles ont été séparées par la langue une
langue française une langue anglaise et
le cette partie là du Cameroun avait le
choix de te rattaché au Nigeria ou au
Cameroun donc ils ont choisi le Cameroun
où ils avaient leur culture le tradition
et leurs attaches ce n'est pas très
simple à gérer mais les Camerounais
quand ils se retrouvent entre eux qu'ils
soient du nord du sud ils se sentent ils
se sentent un en fait ils se sentent
proches mais il y a un sentiment
national il y a un sentiment national
qui est extrêmement fort qui est qui est
même
exacerber dans certains cas oui
surgueilleux c'est ce qu'on dit des
Camerounais non fort
alors vous allez une particularité c'est
que vous êtes une artiste polyvalente
romancière avec les aquatiques qui est
un magnifique roman récompensé par de
nombreux prix en 2021 vous êtes
également photographe et vous avez
exposé beaucoup de vos photos là on voit
des photos qui ont été prises au Congo
Kinshasa et puis vous êtes réalisatrice
de longs métrages une affaire de [__]
zérod seconde classe en Algérie en
Israël c'était en 2011 au-delà de la
peine c'est histoire dans des prisons
vous êtes une artiste engagée au sens
sartrien du terme c'est à dire politique
Sartre qui a dit la nausée ne fait guère
le poids devant un enfant qui meurt de
faim
je crois que je suis
j'aurais du mal à faire de la pour là et
en même temps je me sens écarté par deux
polarités celle de m'investir dans le
beau ce que je j'essaie de faire aussi
un peu comme
le décret Nathaniel autorne dans
l'artiste du beau et en même temps il y
a un côté aussi hugolien chez moi qui
est
l'ultime vient de se conscrire le beau
le sublime donc je suis très partagée
entre les deux je suis à chaque fois
entre entre ces deux polarités là est-ce
que je suis engagée c'est difficile de
le dire parce que ça se sent souvent
militants et moi ça me gêne quand même
non je ne suis pas militante je ne suis
pas militante je pense à partir du
moment où on fait de l'art on s'engage
il n'y a pas il n'y a pas
que vous êtes en train de préparer donc
c'est sur l'Insee le mouvement qui a
lutté contre l'apartheid avec Nelson
Mandela en Afrique du Sud alors je fais
mon prochain documentaire qui va être
diffusé sur plusieurs chaînes de
télévision donc des canal et la
télévision suisse c'est sur une comptine
qui veut dire la lance de la nation
c'est la branche armée de la NC que
Mandela avait initié créé et commander
en 61 et le c'est un film qui est aussi
un portrait en creux de Mandela un
Mandela qui est un chef de guerre qui
est un commandant d'une armée de
guérilla
qu'on ne connaît pas trop et je voulais
sortir un peu de cette vision très
spartiale très réécrite pacifiste de
Mandela il est devenu pacifiste Mandela
mais il est venu sur le tard et je crois
que le
le capitalisme
occidental a réécrit cette image de
Mandela parce que c'était plus
intéressant de présenter ce papier à
chemise à fleurs qu'il est devenu bien
sûr mais mais le celui qui s'est battu
pour la libération de son de son pays et
qui a été finalement contraint de
prendre les armes de prendre le maquis
ce visage là est moins connu et je
t'inquiète voilà et c'est ça rééquilibre
un peu le visage de Mandela très lisse
le film raconte aussi la philosophie
d'aujourd'hui à travers les anciens
soldats de la branche armée de Mandela
que j'ai retrouvé et le désenchantement
qui est le leur puisque ils se sont
quand même battus pour un idéal et cette
idéal aujourd'hui a été foulée au pied
tout à l'heure vous en parlez de
littérature vous êtes romancière c'est
qui votre romancier préféré dans
l'Afrique en Afrique
alors j'hésite entre chinois H&B et
Kuruma mais je pense que c'est Kuruma
nigérien
qui a toujours été en lutte contre la
corruption dans son uniquement dans son
pays mais j'ai rien est un pays où la
corruption est importante pas assez
connue en France d'ailleurs puisqu'il
est de langue anglaise et puis Kourouba
alors lui qui est de langue française
d'origine enfin ivoirien
Allah n'est pas obligé c'est sur les
enfants soldats le soleil des
indépendances oui Kuruma j'ai découvert
que Romain adolescente et sa façon
irrévérencieuse de triturer le français
de le malinkisé cette humour qu'il avait
dans cet textes cette liberté m'a
décomplexé quand j'ai voulu quand j'ai
commencé à penser à écrire il est des
auteurs qui m'ont donné envie de devenir
écrivaine
merci
Oswald le Watt merci beaucoup
c'est moi merci beaucoup
[Musique]